shouldn't an executive producer know
more about money than they should have
bad storytelling well an executive
producer if they're doing their job
right should know just as much about
storytelling as they are about money
because whoever giving them the money
has an expectation of what story you're
going to tell them so there's a script
that they've given you the money for so
it's now your job to deliver that at the
price that they gave you so yes it's
very important you know how to put
financing together and know how to deal
with banks and loans and tax credits and
advances and all that on the other hand
the person who's giving you the money
has an expectation that the directors
gonna direct the movie that they bought
and the actors are gonna act the movie
that they bought and so the only person
that's going to make sure that that
train doesn't run off the tracks is the
executive producer so the line producers
real job is what time is it and are we
done the line producer jobs just make
sure okay I have this much money to
spend on this day and that's what we're
gonna spend he doesn't have any creative
responsibility nor should he
it's the upm and the line producers job
to get it done at the price so it's the
executive producer who has to kind of be
the referee between the part that's
pulling for money being saved and the
part that's pulling for let's do the
best movie possible and that's the
director's job is not to worry about the
money you don't want them to think about
money you want them to think about
what's the best movie I can make and you
want your line producer to say you can't
do that because we can't afford it and
so someone has to referee and get the
best movie possible for the price so how
do we debt the very best movie the very
best art for the price tag that we've
been given that's the executive
producers job so I don't think you need
to know one or the other more I think
you actually need to know the more you
can do both of those jobs
I think the easier it is to mediate
what's the most common question your
students ask you I think the most common
question my students ask me is who was
the worst actor you've ever worked with
[Music]
but I think that my students biggest
question is what do we do when we
graduate
what's the world that's out there for
them and I think it's my job to give
them the tools to be able to succeed
whether they get hired initially on the
line producing side or on the executive
producing side or as a studio executive
a lot of my students go on to be
development executives because they've
learned how to hear a pitch and to pitch
themselves
the thing about pitching is it's not
just when you go to sell it to a studio
or network you're gonna pitch an agent
you're gonna pitch a star you're gonna
pitch a cinematographer you're gonna
pitch an editor hey I want you to come
aboard this project let me tell you a
story
so you're pitching all the time no
matter what part of the business you're
in so to not have that skill in your to
not have that arrow in your quiver is a
just I think a huge detraction to your
career and it would be remiss upon us as
filmmaking professors not to give you
that
so the continuation of storytelling not
just within the confines of a hundred
and twenty page script but with someone
to allow you to come in and pitch to
them with someone that you're sending
out the script to that's a potential
investor you know everything is scary
when you leave film school it's all
frightening will I succeed will I make
it will I be the one that gets to live
out the dream and I think it's part of
our responsibility as experienced
filmmakers and professors to try and
calm some of those fears by telling them
what it's going to be like to give them
realistic expectations
but also to give them enough tools that
no matter what situation they get and
whether they're making the movie on
their phone for 25,000 or they get hired
to do you know twenty five million
dollar sequel to something that they
have those tools and all of it comes
back to storytelling what about the
definition of the dream do you think
it's the same for most of the students
do you think there's skewed by wanting
their picture and variety whereas people
can be working in the industry they
work all year long maybe people don't
know them as a household name but
they're still living out being creative
being on a set I think the most
disappointed you will be in our business
if you live for the fame and the fortune
I had to learn that lesson the hard way
Peter Guber was helpful in teaching me
that that really the reason we do this
is the process if you don't enjoy the
doing if you don't enjoy every part of
getting that script ordered into
production and then going on a set and
then sitting in an editing room or
sitting on a mixing stage that's the
part I got depressed after I saw my
first credit on screen
I lied awake all night not understanding
why I wasn't happier and it took some
therapy and a couple of conversations
with Peter Guber to figure out that that
wasn't the be-all end-all seeing my name
on the screen for the first time which
is what I thought it would be
it was the getting to do it to see my
name on the screen which is also part of
why I don't love watching myself again
and I mean I think it's the doing that I
love and then when it's over it's over
and I'm on to the next I want to know
what the next challenge is gonna be I
don't love watching stuff that's already
been made because that was the process
then and I want to find the new process
I want to find the new road to get on
and do you think your son's saw you that
you instilled that in them somehow
whether it was just by them watching you
because they have this successful
channel and so many people set out to
have a youtube channel they don't reach
that level I think that my son's had the
benefit of being around really good
storytellers in their house whether it
was me whether it was their mother who
also is in the business of telling
stories that television movie network
whether it be screenwriters that were
friends of mine that their Godfather
runs Marvel television and they were
blessed to hear him tell stories all the
time and then we you know we made it a
point to you can't come home from school
and just say it was a good day you got
to tell me a story so I think they were
and they were
you know indoctrinated with storytelling
at a young age and I think they were
blessed to have really good storytellers
around them telling stories that they
could hear it and soak it up like little
sponges and you know they went to really
good schools that taught them how to be
good storytellers as well that
definitely helped both of their colleges
are great liberal arts college I'm a big
believer in not going to film school as
an undergrad I don't think you learn
what you need in an undergraduate film I
think if you want to take a graduate
course if you want to go and get an MA
or MFA that's great and I think AFI and
USC and NYU UCLA are great AFI the best
but I don't think as an undergrad that's
what you should be doing I think it's an
undergrad you should be taking
literature and architecture and art
classes I mean I can tell you I don't
use my film school knowledge anywhere
near as much as I use my undergraduate
Brandeis degree I will tell you they've
if I'm sitting with a composer I'm not
gonna talk about frames per second we're
gonna talk about box and Beethoven and
talking heads I mean that's what a
musician wants to talk about
well that's stuff I learned in college
not in film school if I'm with a set
designer what I learned in my one
architecture class comes in handy when I
see with a screen writer you know what I
learned in English Lit and history and
social studies and politics that all
comes in handy not you know how much
does it cost to put a light on a set and
what is what are the fringes for a
screenwriter you know that's important
and I love my AFI education they're
gonna be a good filmmaker and a good
storyteller you really do need a liberal
arts education
you